c'est le retour des files d'attente
avant de faire son plein dans cette
station de service bordelaise le prix du
gazole devrait passer d'un euro 61 à
1,91 mercredi
ça provoque une ruée donc vous venez
de provoquer sans doute un appel à la
ruée pour ceux qui auraient oublié ce
matin les recherches sont terminées dans
ce quartier du centre de Lille toujours
bouleversé je me suis jamais allé dans
une aucune émission de Cyril Hanouna bon
donc mais pour parce que c'est un choix
personnel parce que c'est un choix
personnel que j'ai fait dès le début et
pour autant je n'incrimine pas celles et
ceux qui ont fait le choix d'aller chez
Cyril Hanouna parce que continuer c'est
aussi c'est aussi courageux que d'être
allé d'être capable dans des endroits
qui sont pas aussi calmes que des
plateaux comme le vôtre on peut parler
de politique parce qu'il faut toucher
tous les publics le bâtiment a pourtant
été emporté par l'effondrement du 44 les
autres occupants n'étaient pas sur place
par miracle peut-être que j'irai un jour
je vérifierai que les conditions sont
réunies en aucun cas je ne supporterai
la victime l'insulter l'injure je ne
souhaite pas être première ministre je
j'ai d'autres ambitions c'est d'être
présidente de la République et ça ne
passe pas par la case Matignon la
présidente du groupe rassemblement
national à l'Assemblée l'affirme ce
matin dans le JDD donc c'est vous qui
allez
non ça n'a pas été ça n'a pas été décidé
nous verrons mais imaginez juste si vous
voulez
si Marine Le Pen il va pas faut bien
quelqu'un y a c'est chef du parti
bah pas forcément c'est une campagne de
régularisation je la cite orchestrée à
la demande du patronat afin de faire
baisser les salaires vous répondez quoi
cet argument de Marine Le Pen que le
rassemblement national soit raciste
c'est pas une nouveauté mais moi je sais
pas si vous voulez je vous intéresser
c'est pas le sujet ça vous intéresse ou
pas je n'arrive pas de devant la glace
le matin en me rasant en me disant j'ai
envie d'être à Matignon il y a besoin de
régulariser tous ces travailleurs et ces
travailleuses justement afin d'éviter
cette réalité qui existe déjà qu'il soit
exploité l'ouverture finalement à
l'échelle Viking du port de Toulon c'est
l'ouverture de la boîte de Pandore et
puis je suis numéro 2 du parti que vous
avez expliqué que j'étais formidable que
j'étais la vitrine de la dédiabolisation
que j'étais libération l'incarnation oh
peut-être qu'elle libération pourra
trouver des papiers en ce sens j'étais
le la caution moderne du parti
l'immigration n'est pas une
pour la France et pour l'Europe
l'immigration est grosse d'un certain
nombre de faits qui pourraient devenir
extrêmement sérieux la destruction de la
cohésion de notre société là en 24
heures depuis que je de numéro 2 à
numéro 1 j'ai évolué dans cette fonction
je suis le mal absolu l'horreur l'erreur
radicalisation etc les démocrates
respirent ils gardent la majorité au
Sénat Joe Biden s'en est d'ailleurs
félicité hier le parti a remporté le
siège du Nevada les démocrates qui
devraient en revanche perdre la Chambre
des représentants sur Twitter oui il y a
une espèce de bronca systématique dès
que je fais un tweet dès que je parle je
rappelle quand même que Twitter il y a
une stratégie des mouvements notamment
d'extrême droite sur Twitter pour tenir
et influencer le débat je pense que ça
en est la preuve et d'ailleurs ça pose
une question sur l'arrivée d'Elon musk
sur Twitter et de la suite qu'on va
donner à ce réseau social moi-même je me
pose la question d'y rester ou pas
pas de problème avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je pense que sur son blog il est parfois
outrancier peut-être sectaire aussi dans
le ciel de Dallas B17 de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
subitement percuté
[Musique]
aujourd'hui est un instrument de
propagande et je le dis comme ça on voit
des raids des cyber-harcèlement on l'a
vu avec facebook lors de la campagne de
Trump aujourd'hui twitter fait partie de
ses réseaux sociaux qui sont
instrumentalisés je pense que il vaut
mieux se parler plutôt que de laisser
aller de se laisser aller sur les blogs